c'est
merci mes amis inquiets merci merci
merci mes amis il y à plus de 100 ans
un grand premier ministre wilfred
laurier a parlé des voix ensoleillée ils
savaient que la politique peut être une
force positive et c'est le message que
les canadiens ont envoyé aujourd'hui
les canadiens ont choisi le changement
un vrai changement
sonny wade my friend les voix
ensoleillée les voix ensoleillée baisse
cela est ce que la politique positive
peut accomplir cvg ce qu'une vision
d'espérance et une plate forme une
équipe peuvent réaliser les habitants du
pays les habitants du pays
partout à travers notre nous disposés à
15 ans ont demandé des changements pour
ce pays un changement véritable
il ya tellement de gens à remercier ce
soir et je passais beaucoup de temps
dans les jours à venir à les remercier
mais je veux commencer par ma famille
j'aimerais d'abord remercier ma famille
se fit aviez l agresser adrien
merci de m'avoir terni le service merci
sophy pour ta force pour ta campath
compassion pour ta grandeur d'âme et
pour ta générosité profonde et et xavier
est l'agressé adrien qui fondent au dos
maintenant que me qui seront avec nous
demain matin mes enfants on embarque
dans une nouvelle aventure ensemble et
je peux vous dire maintenant qui va
avoir des moments difficiles pour vous
en tant qu'enfant de premier ministre
mais papa sera là pour vous servir
je veux aussi remercier les gens qui me
font confiance depuis 2008 les gens de
papineau
merci encore une fois de votre appui
merci de votre confiance je suis d'abord
et avant tout fier de vous représenter à
la chambre des communes vous mes chers
concitoyens papineau vous m'aviez choix
parler des enjeux qui sont importants
pour vous je vous ai entendu et cela m'a
aidé à devenir un meilleur député à
devenir un meilleur chef et cela va
m'aider à devenir un meilleur premier
ministre
à la hausse également
je veux remercier plus spécifiquement
mon bon ami thierry terre eau feu dès
mon amitié vos bottes qui lui sont des
personnes qui travaillent le plus dur où
que ce soit que vous puissiez trouver et
qu'ils sont d'accord avec moi la
politique n'a pas besoin d'être négative
et abarth attaques personnelles pour
connaître le succès et que vous pouvez
faire appel aux côtés angely que de
notre nature et pouvait compter sur moi
pour le faire
ce soir mes bons amis
nous avons prouvé cela et j'espère que c
est une inspiration pour les gens qui
pensent comme nous de se lever et de se
joindre à nous de s'impliquer dans la
vie publique de ce pays est de savoir
qu'une vision de la vie publique
optimisme n'est pas un rêve naïf
ça peut être une force puissance en
faveur du changement
je veux également remercier tous nos
incroyables bénévoles qui sont à la base
de notre succès de ce soir que 80 mille
citoyens se sont impliqués dans cette
campagne
ils ont frappé aux portes de leurs
voisins ils ont fait des appels
téléphoniques ils s'envoyaient des
courriels des centaines de milliers de
plus nous ont soutenu de manière active
avec leurs amis en ligne ont convaincu
leurs voisins et leurs familles et tous
ces gens avaient une chose en commun ils
se souciaient profondément de leur
famille de leur communauté et de leur
pays ils croyaient que le meilleur est
possible et que les citoyens actifs
peuvent être partie prenante jouer un
rôle efficace pour que tout cela à la
baisse mais maintenant de ce mouvement
que nous avons bâti et est alimenté par
c
bénévole incroyable et du fond du coeur
je vous remercie
maintenant je voudrais prendre quelques
secondes pour parler de mes collègues
partout dans l'île et j'ai reçu bien sûr
des effets techniques de leur part y
compris de monsieur steven à peu il a
servi ce pays depuis une décennie
et comme ceux qui ont consacré leur vie
à ce pays nous le remercions pour ses
bons et loyaux services
non maintenant durant cette campagne
j'ai eu l'occasion de pour avoir
quelconque conversation brève avec lui
nous avons discuté de nos familles ça me
rappelait les sacrifices extraordinaires
lignes qui ont été faits par quiconque a
servi ce pays au plus haut niveau et je
voudrais rappeler à tous tel que j'ai
dit plusieurs fois durant cette campagne
les conservateurs ne sont pas nos
ennemis ce sont nos voisins
mais douch le leadership consiste à
rassembler les gens de différents points
de vue tous ensemble mulcair qui a mené
une campagne vigoureuse il s'est battu
jusqu'à la fin
aux militants de son parti
je comprends votre déception ce soir
notre parti a vécu des moments
difficiles
il n'y a pas si longtemps alors ne vous
découragez pas notre payer a besoin de
citoyens engagés comme vous
notre pays en sera plus fort merci
non maintenant vous allez tous entendre
bien des choses demain soir à propos de
moi même de notre campagne bien des gens
auront toutes sortes d'opinions à propos
de notre succès est bien durant trois
ans nous avions une stratégie un plus
ancien
nous avons parlé avec autant de
canadiens que nous l'avons vu et nous
les avons écoutés nous avons gagné cette
élection parce que nous avons écouté
nous avons fait le dur travail de se
promener partout au pays quatre
rencontres et des centaines de personnes
en plein milieu de l'hiver en arctique
avec des milliers de personnes à brenton
au milieu de la campagne vous avez bâti
cette plateforme vous savez bâti ce
mouvement
vous nous avez dit ce dont vous avez
besoin pour connaître le succès nous
avons v10 quel genre de gouvernement
voulait et nous avons italie les plans
pour le faire advenir dans les cafés
dans les hôtels de ville a fait dans les
églises vous avez passé du temps pour
venir nous voir et vous nous avez parlé
du genre de pays que vous voudriez voir
bâti et que vous voudriez laisser à vos
enfants
tous les jours vous nous avez dit que ça
devenait de plus en plus difficile de
joindre les deux bouts et de payer les
factures à la fin du mois vous nous avez
dit que vous étiez inquiet pour votre
retraite vous nous avez dit que vos
communautés avaient besoin
d'investissements vous nous avez dit que
les bons emplois se faisaient de plus en
plus rares vous êtes l'inspiration
derrière notre programme
vous êtes la raison pour laquelle nous
avons travaillé si fort pour nous rendre
là où nous sommes ce soir
et vous serez toujours au coeur du
gouvernement que nous allons former aux
ducasses ces dernières trois années vous
nous avez dit ce que vous viviez que
qu'il était de plus en plus difficile de
joindre les deux bouts et vous nous avez
fait part de vo préoccupation pour
savoir si vous pourriez avoir une
retraite digne
et vous avez dit que vos communautés
avaient besoin d'investissements vous
nous avez dit que vous recherchiez des
emplois meilleur vous avez été
l'inspiration pour nos efforts vous est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
travaillé si fort pour être ici ce soir
et vous serez au coeur des
préoccupations de ce nouveau
gouvernement
alors mon message à vous ce soir mes
chers concitoyens est très simple
ayez foi en vous même et dans votre pays
et sachez que nous pouvons réaliser tout
ce que nous voudrons si nous nous y
concentrons si nous travaillons fort
c'est vous
ne laissez pas les gens vous dira le
contraire je sais que je suis ici ce
soir pour une seule raison parce que
vous m'avez choisi haye de doute mais
question et ce n'est pas moi qui ai fait
l'histoire ce soir c'est vous qui l'avez
fait et ne laissez personne vous dire le
contraire
je sais que je suis ici au podium ce
soir pour une raison et une seule parce
que vous m'avez mis ici
et vous m'avez donné une feuille de
route claire vous le gouvernement qui va
travailler aussi fort que vous qui va se
concentrer
chaque minute de chaque jour pour faire
croître l'économie et créer des emplois
et renforcer la classe moyenne
un gouvernement qui va aider les
familles canadiennes les plus démunis à
passer éventuellement dans la classe
moyenne
vous voulez un premier ministre qui
connaît le canada un pays fort non pas
en dépit de nos différences mais à cause
de ces mêmes différences un premier
ministre qui ne veut jamais diviser les
canadiens mais qui saisit toute occasion
pour nous rassembler vous voulez un
premier ministre qui sait je si les
canadiens doivent faire confiance à leur
gouvernement
le gouvernement doit faire confiance aux
canadiens un premier ministre qui
comprend que l'ouverture la transparence
signifie des décisions meilleur et plus
réfléchie vous voulez un premier
ministre qui sait qu'une que des
relations renouvelées de nation à nation
avec les peuples autochtones qui
respecte les droits et qui en or les
traités et ce que vous voulez et cela
doit être la base de notre travail pour
combler l'écart et travailler de concert
ensemble à mes compatriotes québécois
ce soir ensemble nous avons choisi la
voie de l'engagement
nous avons choisi de se réengager dans
une politique plus rassembleuse plus
positive nous avons choisi de se
réengager dans la gouverne d'un pays
pour qui reflète nos valeurs et nos
ambitions nous avons choisi de faire
confiance et d investir ensemble dans
notre avenir
au cours des trois dernières années j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps allez à votre
rencontre et à vous écouter vous m'aviez
dit que vous vouliez un gouvernement
ouvert et transparent
un gouvernement qui fait confiance en
ses citoyens un gouvernement au service
de tous les canadiens et les canadiennes
ce soir c'est l'engagement que je prends
devant vous je serai le premier ministre
de tous les canadiens
lou forme mon gouvernement intègre qui
respectera les institutions et qui fera
de la collaboration avec les provinces
le principe premier de ces actions chers
amis québécois
merci ce soir le canada retrouve un peu
de lui même ce soir le québec fait un
véritable retour au gouvernement du
canada
les canadiens ont parlé vous voulez un
gouvernement avec une vision un agenda
qui sera des plus ambitieux et qui sera
porteur d'espérance et bien mes amis je
vous promets ce soir que je serai le
leader de ce gouvernement
je ferai en sorte que cette vision
devienne une réalité je serai ce premier
ministre durant cette élection 10 792
citoyens se sont levés ont mis leur nom
sur les bulletins de vote et se sont
portés candidats
382 été choisi par vous pour être leur
voix à ottawa et je m'engage ce soir à
les écouter tous
il y a mis l'histoire que je pourrai
partager avec vous un propos de cet
extraordinaire quand même il en est une
en particulier la semaine dernière j'ai
rencontré une jeune mère à st catherines
en ontario
elle était musulmane et portait un vix
jab
elle a passé à travers la poule et elle
m'a peu tendu sa petite fille et
qu'intel s'est penché vers moi il m'a
dit quelque chose que je n'oublierai
jamais elle a dit que l bottai pour nous
parce que voulait s'assurer que sa
petite fille aurait le droit de faire
ses propres choix dans la vie et que le
gouvernement protégerait ses droits
haïti va cette femme je dis vous et vos
concitoyens avaient choisi un nouveau
gouvernement un gouvernement qui croit
profondément dans la diversité de notre
pays nous savons dans notre moi le même
que le canada était batié par des gens
de partout au monde qui ont toutes
sortes de foi appartiennent à toutes
sortes de cultures et parlent toutes
sortes de langues
nous croyons au plus profond de notre
coeur que la diversité unique de ce pays
est une bénédiction qui nous a été
laissée par les générations précédentes
qui ont lutté contre les préjugés et
combattu la discrimination sous toutes
ses formes
nous savons que notre société enviable
inclusive n'est pas arrivé par accident
et ne m'étonnera que par nos efforts
j'ai toujours reçu cela nos concitoyens
le savent également fait sinon j'aurais
pu parler un peu plus tôt ce soir et je
répète vous livrer un discours tout à
fait différent ayez foi en vous
concitoyens ils sont bons ils sont
généreux ils sont ouverts d'esprit et
optimistes et ils savent au fond de leur
coeur canadien c'est un canadien c'est
un canadien
et céline nous avons battu la paire avec
l'espoir
nous avons battu le cynisme avec le
travail acharné nous avons battu la
politique négative avec une vision
rassembleuse et positive
my friends mes amis nous avons vaincu la
peur avec l'espérance le cynisme avec du
travail
nous avons vaincu la politique divise iv
négative avec une vision qui a rassemblé
tous les habitants du pays
de plus nous avons battu l'idée des
faits l'idée que nous consommions
devrait se contenter du moindre et que
bon bah le meilleur n'était pas
nécessairement possible et bien mes amis
ceux ci c'est le canada et au canada le
meilleur est toujours possible merci
merci beaucoup